♪
>> Jeanine: DID WOKE POLICIES
COST KIDS THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN SCHOLARSHIPS?
VIRGINIA IS NOW THE EPICENTER OF
THIS DAMAGING EQUITY CRUSADE.
AT LEAST 13 SCHOOLS THERE ARE
BEING ACCUSED OF WITHHOLDING
MERIT AWARDS FROM TOP STUDENTS
AFTER THE COLLEGE APPLICATION
CYCLE.
IT WAS REPORTEDLY DONE TO AVOID
HURT FEELINGS, BUT THE PARENTS
SAY THE MOVE CHEATED THEIR KIDS
OUT OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF SCHOLARSHIPS.
GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN IS OUTRAGED,
SAYING, QUOTE, THEY HAVE A
MANIACAL FOCUS ON EQUAL OUTCOMES
FOR ALL STUDENTS AT ALL COSTS,
AND HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
VOWING TO INVESTIGATE.
>> ONE OF THEIR DIRECTIVE TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS EQUAL
OUTCOMES NO MATTER WHAT, EVEN IF
IT MEANS TREATING SOME STUDENTS,
QUOTE, PURPOSESY EQUALLY.
ONE MOTHER SAYS, MY DAUGHTER
HAS WORKED HARD, AND MAY NOT GO
TO THE SCHOOL OF HER DREAM
BECAUSE SHE'S KOREAN AMERICAN.
THAT GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING WE
BELIEVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jeanine: DANA, YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE DRIP, DRIP, DRIP.
>> Dana: THIS ONE TOO.
>> Jeanine: WE HEARD ABOUT ONE
SCHOOL, THEN IT WAS AT THAT
SCHOOL, AND HEARING MORE AND
MORE ABOUT OTHER SCHOOLS.
SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS AN ORGANIZED
EFFORT TO KEEP THE INFORMATION
AWAY FROM KIDS.
>> Dana: THE PARENTS HAPPENED TO
SEE THE LETTER FROM THE NATIONAL
MERIT SCHOLARS ASSOCIATION ON
THEIR CHILD'S DESK AT HOME
RANDOMLY.
WHAT'S THIS?
OH, WE JUST GOT IT.
OH, OKAY.
THAT'S WHEN THE PARENT CALLS.
THEY SAY, OH, THIS WAS A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE.
IT'S AN ABERRATION.
THIS IS NOT ANYTHING HAPPENING
ANYWHERE ELSE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL YOU JUST
SAW, HE RAN HIS CAMPAIGN, WHEN
HE WAS RUNNING FOR OFFICE, ON
ROOTING OUT THIS WOKE NONSENSE
THAT PRIORITIZES EQUITY AND
RACIAL SEGREGATION OVER MERIT.
SO HE SAID, I'M GOING TO LOOK
INTO THIS.
WELL, IT'S ONLY BEEN ABOUT 10
DAYS.
NOW WE KNOW THAT 13 SCHOOLS WERE
DOING THIS.
I WANT TO KNOW IF IT'S JUST IN
VIRGINIA OR A NATIONWIDE THING.
IS IT, LIKE, A SECRET BAT SIGNAL
THAT GOES OUT TO THE SCHOOLS,
LIKE DON'T PUT IT IN WRITING,
BUT LET'S ALL MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T UPSET ANYBODY BY MAKING
SURE THEY DON'T FEEL BAD IF THEY
DON'T GET A NATIONAL MERIT
SCHOLARSHIP.
BUT THIS IS A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S GOING FOR ON
THIS ONE.
THE OTHER THING IS, THERE'S A
GROUP CALLED PARENTS DEFENDING
EDUCATION, AND THEY'VE DEVELOPED
A MASSIVE DATABASE TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE SCHOOLS USING PUBLIC
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO HIRE WOKE
CONSULTANTS, WHERE IT WAS GOING.
THEY FOUND ABOUT $20 MILLION IN
CONTRACTS NATIONWIDE.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF IT WAS SPENT IN
VIRGINIA.
HE'S DOING WHAT HE CAMPAIGNED
ON.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT TURNS OUT.
>> Jeanine: BRIAN, THE SCHOOLS
INITIALLY SAID, YOU KNOW, IT'S
BECAUSE OF HUMAN ERROR, IT WAS A
UNIQUE SITUATION.
AND NOW WE'VE GOT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, HE'S GOING TO SUE FOR
UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION, A
VIOLATION OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT.
>> Brian: YOU WOULD KNOW BETTER,
BUT IF YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO GET A
SCHOLARSHIP, YOU GET A MERIT
AWARD, THESE INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SUE.
YOUNGKIN SLAMMED THE DISTRICT
FOR HIRING A $450,000 A YEAR
EQUITY COACH.
THIS STARTED WITH THE
VALEDICTORIANS.
THEY DECIDED NOT TO HAVE ONE,
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT EVERYBODY
ELSE TO FEEL BAD FOR NOT WORKING
AS HARD OR BEING AS SMART.
THAT WAS NOTHING COMPARED TO
THIS, BUT WE'VE GOT TO SMART.
THE ASIAN AMERICANS SUED TO GET
RID OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, AND
THEY'RE GETTING SCREWED BECAUSE
THEY OUTWORK EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT A KID WHO
HAS A DREAM, CAN RUN FASTER,
WORKS HARDER, TO ACHIEVE THAT
DREAM?
>> Geraldo: ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS UNFAIR.
IT'S CREEPY.
IT MAY BE CRIMINAL WHAT THEY DID
INTENTIONALLY DENYING
NOTIFICATION OF WINNING A MERIT
SCHOLARSHIP SO YOU COULDN'T PUT
IT ON YOUR RESUME, SO YOU DON'T
GET IN THE COLLEGE OF YOUR
CHOICE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MANY ASIAN
AMERICAN KIDS AFFECTED BY THIS.
THIS IS ROTTEN.
I THINK THAT -- I BELIEVE THIS
IS WORSE THAN THE SCANDAL,
PEOPLE PAYING TO BE ON THE FAKE
ROWING TEAM AND ALL THAT.
I THINK THIS WILL BE A BIGGER
STORY.
>> Brian: IT SHOULD BE.
>> Geraldo: THIS IS AWFUL WHAT
THEY'VE DONE TO THESE CHILDREN.
>> Jeanine: MOST OF THE KIDS
AFFECTED BY THIS, WERE ASIAN
AMERICAN KIDS.
IT'S INTERESTING THEY STOPPED
ADMITTING THEM IN THE NUMBERS
THEY HAD PREVIOUSLY.
>> Geraldo: I'M PRETTY SURE THIS
HAPPENED TO ME.
>> Brian: DID YOU A FULL RIDE TO
UCLA BASKETBALL?
>> Greg: BECAUSE THE MERIT
SCHOLARSHIP DIDN'T COME THROUGH.
NOW I HAD TO GO TO MY SECOND
SCHOOL, BERKELEY.
>> Brian: I'M SORRY TO HEAR
THAT.
>> Greg: WHERE DID YOU GO?
>> Brian: I DIDN'T GO.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T THINK SO.
ACTIVISTS WANT EVERYBODY, THE
CASUAL OBSERVER, TO REPLACE THE
WORD "EQUALITY" WITH" EQUITY."
BEGINS WITH E-Q-U.
YOU HEAR MORE ABOUT QUALITY AND
LESS THAN EQUITY.
YOU ASKED SOMEBODY WHAT DOES
EQUITY MEAN, AND THEY'LL USE A
TERMINOLOGY FOR QUALITY
EQUALITY, BUT IT'S NOT THE SAME.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE DIFFERENCE
IS.
ONE IS ABOUT PEACE AND THE OTHER
IS ABOUT WAR.
EQUALITY IS DEFINED AS PEOPLE
HAVING THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES TO
ACHIEVE THE SAME GOALS.
WE'RE ALL AT THE SAME STARTING
PLACE.
EQUITY IS WE ENFORCE LIMITS ON
ACHIEVEMENT SO NO ONE ACHIEVES
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE.
THAT PUNISHES THE REALLY HARD
WORKERS.
THAT LEADS TO WAR.
THAT'S SOCIALISM.
SO EQUITY -- EQUALITY GIVES
EVERYBODY A STEP UP.
EQUITY CRUSHES FROM ABOVE.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER -- WE HAVE
TO REMIND YOURSELF OF THIS,
WHENEVER YOU RUN INTO THIS
SITUATION, BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO ALWAYS TRY TO REPLACE
EQUALITY WITH EQUITY, AND YOU
CAN SEE IT, LIKE IN NEWS
REPORTS, THEY'LL LET THE WORD
"EQUITY" FLY BY.
THAT'S AN EVIL WORD.
IT IS A WORD THAT CAUSED
COMM